[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to huniepop I know it's
probably not pronounced huniepop but at
this point I'm already too deep into the
welder try to deviate up this book
anyway we're talking to the mega [ __ ]
here but I need to upgrade my stats I
think I think I could do that I'm pretty
sure I can do that I'm pretty sure I can
do that maybe if I do a little bit uh
charisma look yes okay so I got both of
those and then I'm doing better so now
I'll be able to get more points I'll be
able to know what I'm doing Oh
everything having to weed through all
the benches that one that's something I
don't have so don't talk to me
[Music]
junk food in fruit okay
I'm gonna shove your face fill of junk
food and fruit like eggplant a mango
tomato is a fruit
technically speaking and junk food like
cupcakes I'm gonna shove these in your
face and you're gonna accept it
wait is it a vegetable or fruit I think
of a fruit by definition is anything
that contains the seed well you did I
shoved it in your face and you accepted
it aren't you happy junk food is it food
maybe corn dogs whatever you are just a
delight we should go on a date right
[Music]
I'm your host right now oh good you know
just it's nice weather we're having here
okay I gotta be careful about that
that's gonna break some combos
immediately
that's no good that's no good at all
bang boom how about some of that in your
face didn't like it I know yeah I know
I'm the best fix this is if I knew that
it's just gonna plop down it's gonna do
combo yeah it's gonna do can't have that
this I know I know I know I don't know
[Music]
yes Cabo's okay I'm gonna get this and
then I'm gonna do the bear cuz I need to
get rid of those things but I know I
bought you things therefore you show me
effect really good up like the best not
really
oh damn I need so much more my passion
level is at max mega [ __ ]
[Music]
is not the one eyeball that's bad oh god
oh god no why do i why do I want this
date to be a success anyway it's kind of
the opposite of the effect that I'm
going for here why do I want this to be
a success yep okay somehow I'm winning
this somehow I'm winning this okay I'm
almost there I just gotta get through
this yes I did a deal with the mega
[ __ ]
why am I happy I shouldn't be proud of
what I've done
oh you're welcome I'm glad you love me
with all your heart I'm here for love
[Music]
I'm so happy right okay I'm gonna leave
before I hate you yeah well let me tell
ya oh my god
who don't know let loose have fun chicks
who smoke ugh it's so gross
this one okay sorry mega [ __ ] that's
like just you get cool all right well
comes as you're out
[Music]
like about who do I see you again I
guess let's just go for the loop again
okay boy
ye okay that was fun
I'm glad I did that I hate her with a
passion
oh man a lot of messages got so much
free [ __ ] from this loser that's trying
to get it oh my god whoops I have no
idea or spontaneity in your life I don't
even know what those words mean life
should be a never-ending adventure in
the ultimate couch whatever lips it away
to my bad life oh I tried to get to the
gym whenever I can but sorry oh we're so
incompatible those more compatible with
the mega [ __ ] that's a bit of an
exaggeration I don't appreciate girls
that exaggerate that much okay you know
you like veggies and breakfast veggies
oh do you want I can get you a plan
again you like eggplant you like you
like eggplant you like eggplant I know
you do no not at all it makes me easy it
makes it easy to date a definitely okay
let's hope it's not a devastating
adventure like it was a lesson try this
again
this is the kind of Tuareg you ready to
be emasculated No
[Music]
all right I know cool all right
okay okay okay okay I just got to get
these music ones cuz he doesn't like
anything except for music apparently yes
okay most eggs don't screw this up
don't screw this up Makka Moo you got
this in the bag
I just need to not be stupid like you
always are just don't be you myself
[Music]
ain't no problem no problem baby
I'm getting good this I'm getting real
good at this I'm getting real good at
the dating thing oh man I'll be able to
apply this in the real world real soon
okay good okay thank you glad we went on
whatever this was it was next who did I
see next uh Tiffany right yeah yeah the
student flu
hi funny running into you here hello is
it that funny I bet it's not what's
shakin bacon
I already hate you how are you polar I'm
only five foot four yeah I know how that
feels
oh I wish I was taller oh I wish all my
friends my secret for the such [ __ ]
[Music]
anyway no nothing
uh favorite color okay I have no idea
what that means
you like flirtation you don't like
sexuality let's go on wait let me
purchase a gift first you wait
oh no oh gift type Academy Academy gift
that's okay so I got a gifts ooh Oh get
a getting Academy gift ooh gotta get
them Academy gift she likes pink
okey-dokey then
okay so these are unique to people and I
need to use them specifically on the
right people she might like the bow can
i buy them drinks can i buy them drinks
just can I
Oh lemon drop I got I got exactly
[Music]
it's a little early for that I I
understand I understand a little early
okay I got you I got let's go on it's
gone today
okay sure I bet you'll regret those
words real soon I'm gonna make you feel
so unappreciated on this date
there's gonna be on my phone the entire
time well go to a casino this is getting
harder and harder each time because at
the requirement for points goes up every
single time anymore Moonies I need more
honey I need
I'm gonna go who need four okay so thank
you everybody so much for watching
that's all the huniepop for this episode
here I need to do a lot of work on this
I'm actually going to do some research
on how to play I mean actually like
Susie of the game girls obviously gave
me notes on every single one of these
people and I did not look at any of them
I had no idea I did not pay attention to
anything written here and I am just
failing spectacularly but I got all the
information here so it's all here so I'm
gonna I'm gonna do it next time I'm
gonna do good
so I can't wait for that to happen
anyway so thank you again everybody as
always I'll see you
[Music]
[Applause]